I was recently with John Lewis crossing
the Edmund Pettus Bridge in Selma and
recalling dr. King's leadership John
Lewis's leadership so many who in their
20s had the courage to speak about the
ideals of our country in an environment
where they were exposed to physical harm
to intimidation to hate and ultimately
for dr. King death and fifty years of
reflection on what his life meant is to
reflect on one of the greatest leaders
of our country it is to think about
someone who had the vision to know what
we can be even if we hadn't achieved it
at the point when he lived he was
aspirational but he was also very
realist he understood that those words
we spoke at 1776 have meaning we are all
and should be treated as equals he had
the the knowledge and I think deep faith
to believe that we would hold true to
the ideals that were behind the
principles that were the founding of our
country that the Constitution of the
United States and you know and I've been
reading his writings recently it's just
they gave me inspiration and there's a
whole series of speeches that he gave
about the need for justice and equality
that was about race and and it's gender
and ethnicity and also about economic
justice and when we look at where we are
in this country at this moment in time
we know that those are still issues that
we need to fight for including economic
justice interestingly enough also he he
died 50 years ago so during his life he
was also writing about the importance of
understanding the impact of technology
but he talked about computers and what
we needed to do as the world was
changing and things were being
computerized to think about how
we will achieve equality for everyone in
that new world and in particular workers
and working people and look at where we
are today where we're having these
conversations what will this mean
technology to the workforce what will it
mean in terms of are we going to have an
equal shot everyone at the American
dream will we have equal level of skills
and parity in terms of our value as
working people so those are all the
things I think about when I think about
him I think about the life he lived
which was a life of deep faith and
conviction and belief in our country and
the best of who we are and also a vision
for understanding where we can't be in
and where we might be in the future
nothing is new Under the Sun nothing is
new Under the Sun and he understood that
there are certain values that will be
constant such as love thy neighbor you
know treat each person with dignity and
respect
our value to have a society and a civil
society and and that means a society
that values the lack of violence which
is also about safety and making sure
that we guarantee everyone's safety and
their ability to speak and free speech
and freedom of association and those are
evergreen concepts those are concepts
that are about our values and hopefully
our values stay constant even when
circumstances and the environment may
change the tragedy about his life cut so
short is is the tragedy about people
attempting to kill his voice and but his
voice is and was so powerful that his
voice still we hear it right and in
particular what was tragic is that his
his work was just on the verge of really
pushing for the economic justice piece
before he was killed he remember it was
the sanitation workers he was he was
there to stand for their right to
collective bargain for their right to
have a workplace
would be safe there right to have
dignified wages and and to have the
ability to have a retirement that give
them the ability dignity that's what his
fight was before he was killed and that
is a fight that remains true today you
can go across this country and meet with
hardworking Americans who very much want
to know that if they work hard and they
play by the rules that they will have a
shot at the American Dream that they
will have a shot at homeownership one of
the big issues for students in this
country that they will have a shot at
getting a meaningful education and not
being saddled with student debt these
are all economic issues and these are
all issues that are about economic
justice and dr. King understood that you
can't have equality among people without
everyone having an equal shot at
economic freedom and dignity in that way
you know my parents met when they were
active in the civil rights movement and
so I feel like dr. King and so many of
the leaders of those days were present
in my mind you know at the moment of my
birth and but certainly there have been
different phases in my life that his his
words and his courage and his leadership
have been poignant and including just
recently being in Selma dr. King has
inspired me in so many ways and mostly
it is that he he shows that you can have
the courage to speak certain truths and
even though they may invite a difficult
conversation people will respect those
conversations and and he also most
importantly I think especially at this
moment in time made very clear that we
all have so much more in common than
what separates us and that is such an
important statement that every leader
should make but first they should feel
that and then say it and say it say it
loudly we hope we all as Americans have
so much more in common than what
separates us and we can never succumb to
forces that are about hate or division
we are stronger when we understand that
we are one unified people and and we are
better we are better for it and he
understood that and that inspires me
every day I think that he was one of the
figures of the those days when we were
fighting so much who understood the
power of expression and to to actually
feel that what the people were feeling
and then put those feelings into words I
think that his power was also about his
ability to coalition build again back to
that point about seeing that we have so
much more in common than what separates
us in the midst of being seemingly so
different so he brought together you
know he brought together preachers and
rabbis he brought together people of
every walk of life from every age and
race and every geographic region of the
country he understood that that if he
was going to have that fight on what we
need to do around civil rights but also
economic justice he brought together
organized labor together with the folks
that were you know active in the civil
rights movement understanding that their
their struggles and fight were won and
born out of one one desire which is to
again to have equality I think that's
part of the power that he had he
understood bring people together and and
and you can actually you know succeed I
think it's critically important that we
understand that that these fights these
fights for for fairness for freedom for
equality for justice these are the this
is a this is a fight for something and
not against something and let's be
inspired by that it and and mostly what
he stood for is understanding that this
is about fighting for the best of who we
are as a country
and that fight is born out of love of
country this is a fight that is born out
of love of country and wanting us to be
the best of who we are and highlighting
the best of who we are and fighting for
the ideals that are the basis of who we
are and what makes us Americans if you
know one of my favorite quotes but I'm
gonna tell you it's actually he also
made a really wonderful decision to
marry a woman by the name of Creta Scott
King and actually it's I'm gonna it so
I'm gonna attribute that this is her
quote and I'll paraphrase but she said
the the fight for civil rights the fight
for equality and fight for justice must
be fought and won with each generation
and when she said that I think she
understood he understood that this is
something that is whatever gains we make
they're not going to be permanent that's
the nature of it so let's not lament
let's not be overwhelmed let's not throw
up our hands when it's time to roll up
our sleeves the very nature of it that
we must each and every day fight for the
ideals of our country I think that we
have made great strides and we have a
lot more to do I think that the way that
I think of it is we are I don't I don't
think of it as being a pendulum where we
swing back and forth I don't think it's
that binary I think we we are constantly
striving to do better but it's like a
loop and and sometimes we dip a little
and then we go a little better and then
we dip and then we then we get better
but ultimately we're on an upward
trajectory but I'm an optimist and a
realist I see what's wrong I mean I see
right now that there are certainly
forces of that are sowing hate and
division in our country and and we've
got to you know we have to deal with
that and we have to reject it and we
have to reject certain certain notions
you know people are saying we're a
divided country I don't believe that I
reject that I reject that notion I don't
believe at our core that we're divided I
believe we have so much more in common
what separates us and I and I know that
I know that when people wake up in the
middle of the night with that thought
that is worrying them and weighing on
them they're thinking the same thing and
it is not through the lens of the party
with which they're registered to vote it
has to do with you know their health or
their children or their parents or can
they get a job keep a job pay the bills
the vast majority of us have so much
more in common than what separates us my
dream is that we live to achieve dr.
Kings purpose and that includes equality
that is both about racial justice than
it is about economic justice it is about
all people being treated equally under
the law and in society one of the most
important things that we can do at this
moment in time is remember leaders like
dr. King who who asked us to look in a
mirror and and and think about who we
are as a country and I believe that when
we look in the mirror we will agree that
we are a great country flawed though we
may be but we have to fight for the best
of who we are and that's that's what dr.
King I think wanted us to do which is
ask each of us are we really fighting
for the best of who we are you
challenged us to that way I think